I thought it's on time again I think I'm
going mad
sorry your father's gone at some point
we have to face up to who we are who
were meant to be I think I know where my
dad went that's right in the middle of
the devil sea it would be an adventure
death is an adventure what are you doing
here Laura seven years I've been on a
silent your father nay premiere
[Music]
now I see the lightness intelligence the
recklessness
what do you know about my father Laura
there was more to my life than
boardrooms and business deals there's an
organization called Trinity it's looking
to start a global genocide you dad Jim
you had a bigger holiday got a knack for
the unexpected
you must stop the flora promise me
[Music]
ladies first
[Music]
open the dude
[Music]
[Music]
put it down your finger that's pulling
this trigger you messed with the wrong
family
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's your name Laura Sonny
Croft Lara your father's gone you
couldn't pick up where he left off I see
so much of him in you
pregnant hello sprout if you're
listening to this then I must be dead
I found something a tool called the
mother of death if Trinity succeeds our
world is in danger promise me you will
stop I promise I think I know where my
dad went that's right in the middle of
the devil sea it'll be an adventure
death isn't hotter than adventure
[Music]
[Music]
you shouldn't have come here
but I'm glad that you did
[Music]
what do you know about my father now I
see the lightness the recklessness close
the to once and for the fate of humanity
is now in your hands
[Music]
can't be too careful these days the
world has gone bloody mad I'll take two
you